caught in the act
a foreign vessel found stealing crude
oil deep inside the Creeks of the Niger
Delta
within two days officials decided its
fate
vessels like this worth hundreds of
thousands of dollars can end up in
flames
officials hope this will send a strong
message to all thieves
security situation is not good I can I
am the first to tell you it's not good
at all because
there is a lot of theft
um but it is also not Beyond us
setting such vessels on fire is a rare
Act
most are confiscated and later released
methods of stealing Nigeria's crude oil
are becoming increasingly sophisticated
and security operatives are struggling
to keep up
in the past three months officials have
met significant discoveries
major crude export pipelines have been
illegally tapped
these two pipelines were found running a
distance of four kilometers into the
Atlantic Ocean
thieves have used them to steal oil and
load it onto super tankers
a parliamentary investigation found
Nigeria lost more than two billion
dollars in the first half of 2022 half a
million barrels are stolen daily during
that time in small and large-scale
operations both on and offshore
officiency has said that money could
have addressed Nigeria's growing budget
deficit and widespread poverty
Nigeria has lost so much oil that the
country has lost its position as
Africa's biggest producer
analysts say the Looting of Nigeria's
oil is being carried out by Rogue
security operatives officials and local
communities working together
because of failure of leadership
corruption issues within the system and
the issue of punishment that is not
exacted on those who who participate in
oil theft the loss of all revenue has
forced the government to take on more
borrowing to finance its needs
and that is dangerous to the entire
country the investment climate in
Nigeria and the viability of our
government it is it's Contin
consistently going to weaken the
government's ability to perform
Nigeria has contracted local security
agencies to secure pipelines and revamp
the task force to tackle oil theft
but many analysts say it can only be
stopped by tackling corruption and
effectively managing the production and
supply of oil
the Niger Delta